hey guys it is that day of the week
again rake if you five of the best
gaming stories from the recent past
here's the important stuff this week
gamers realized that a mission in little
gear solid 5 ground zeroes may have been
potentially foreshadowing the split
between Konami and Kajima the mission
asks the player to take control of a
metal gear solid 1era snake and erase
logos of past Miller Gear titles didn't
round the game space whenever a logo
from the game that wasn't directed by
Hideo Kojima is a raised your radio
contact says gorgeous nothing special
once you complete the mission he says
might be able to erase the markings but
the memories will never disappear going
ups with that one conspiracy theorist on
the back of the fifa women's world cup
the FIFA series from EA is featuring
women on the color for the first time in
franchise history which is pretty damn
cool the North Americans its US soccer
star alex Morgan Morgan and lionel messi
vs global cover star are featured on the
ps4 and xbox one box art for FIFA 16
Morgan said it's an incredible honor
through one of the first women featured
on the cover of FIFA I know people all
over the world play this game and I'm
really excited that FIFA 16 is putting
some important spotlight on women's
soccer the Canadian version of the game
will feature their team captain
Christine Sinclair and the all the
addition will feature our very own step
patli figure 16 is the first game in the
series to feature women's teams and the
game is due out on sep tember 27
there's weekend games you can get on the
chief of both xbox and playstation have
some pretty good deal offerings this
week's Xbox one deals with gold include
dark souls 2 scholar of the first sin
for thirty-six bucks the elder scrolls
online Tamriel unlimited for just over
forty dollars and wolfenstein the old
blood for fifteen bucks if you're after
Xbox 360 deals you can get dark souls
for five bucks dark souls 2 420 and red
dead redemption for 749 among heat of
other deals for those of you with sony
consoles you can grab transistor and
Batson on ps4 for five bucks or left and
the Elder Scrolls online is now forty
dollars for a limited time over 1 PS 42
for the full list of deals check out our
stories on gamespot
everybody was super excited for the
witcher 3 to get its 1 point 0 7 patch
and while it did bring in a whole bunch
of school speeches it also accidentally
knocked the game's performance digital
foundry uncovered through a technical
breakdown that the frame rate on both
xbox one and ps4 has been negatively
impacted by the patch on xbox one it
appears that intensive areas like the
crookback bog have pulled the frame rate
down 20 FPS up to 8 FPS slower than it
was in the last version of the game
comparatively the PS thornell struggles
with framerate shutters and lower SPS
readings than the xbox one outputs to
during cutscenes even gamers on PC
aren't all the way out of the woods as
PC gamers have found issues with the
witcher 3 achievements since the last
hatch and finally capcom has revealed
that all street fighter 5 gameplay dlc
can be earned by spending time with the
game instead of your hard-earned dollars
while you will probably still need to
pay up the dlc that is cosmetic capcom
have said that gameplay dlc can be
obtained by either pain or just playing
the game the deaf plan to release
characters individually to give players
something to look forward to and ideally
keep the competitive scene fresh Capcom
have said all balance and system updates
will be free while DLC characters can be
purchased either with fight money or as
any fight money can be earned simply by
playing the game while zeni can be
bought with real world money to save you
the effort of grinding street fighter 5
will have a roster of 16 characters at
launch forum which one you to franchise
appears for beta is currently running
until july twenty eight let me know down
in the comments what you cared about
this week and if you're a fan of how
capcom is going to handle suit by 25
this week on site i tell you about a few
awesome which are three months Lucy
covers off on what's next for Nintendo
and we farewell our friends Kevin
Bernard that is everything I want to
tell you about this week be sure to have
yourself a lovely weekend and I will
catch you again on Monday